[音楽]
[拍手]
生き方改革みなさん毎日のように目にしたり耳にされている言葉じゃないかと思います
企業で働く皆さんは何かしらの取り組みを始められていると思います
結構やってるよっていう会社もあればこれからなんかやんなきゃいけないなぁとか
なんだか社長が急に働きからで方改革やれって言うんだけどどこから始めていいの
みたいな方も結構いらっしゃるかと思います
また学生の皆さんは就職先を選ぶにあたって
ここの会社ブラックじゃないのかなとか説明会では定数た医者だって言ってたけど
ビルを観察に行って夜8時や10時に天気ついてるじゃんみたいなをニュースで出ます
よね
そういうのを耳にすると思うまあが今の学生さんというそういうのを十分
ずいぶん気にしてるんだなあというふうに思います男子学生の方も今ワークライフ
バランスのことをかなり気にしているというデータも出ています
そして政府は一億総活躍プランの中で働き方改革を最大のチャレンジと位置付けていて
かなりこれも強力に推進しようとしています
f の課題意識は人口が減少していくことによって労働力人口が不足していく
それに対してどうしていくかっていうような大きな命題が掲げられています
でもそれちょっとピンと来ないところがあると思います
企業の実態はどうかっていう話です
何が問題なのか一つは長時間労働の問題
政府は残業の上限を定めることにしました
そのことはすごく画期的なことだと思います
ただその上限が今計画しているのは100時間未満っていう数字なんですね
100時間残業するってどういう状態かわかりますか
多分企業で働いている方はだいたいわかっててもうあんなことをやだなあっていう感じ
だと思うんですけど学生さんちょっとピンと来ないかも知れません100時間っていう
のは
前にし月曜から金曜まで朝9時から
5時半まで働いて+10時まで4時間残業しますそれが月曜から企業毎日4週で80
時間
そして土曜日に
約1か月のうち3回でますそして8時間ずっと働いて24時間合計して104時間です
そういう働き方ですつまり休みっていうのは日曜日くらいしかなくて
日曜日疲れてるから午前中だいたい寝てます
午後を切って趣味のことや家事をするともう一日終わってしまう
お子さんにはパパお休みの日も寝てるかいないかどっちかだよねーなんて言われて
そんな生活です
そんなの誰も望んでやっているわけではありません
企業の中でやっている人たちも仕方なく仕事があるからということでやっている状態
です
もう一つの問題は子育て中のママの問題です
短時間勤務をしている人たちは例えば夕方4時には毎日帰らなきゃいけない
その4時までの間に今日の仕事を終わらせなきゃいけないのでかなり一生懸命働きます
必ず4時に帰らなきゃいけないわけです
そして4人に帰るときにはまだ周りのみんなは仕事をしています
その中でお先に失礼しますすいませんって毎日謝るんです
毎日は謝らなきゃいけないっていうその危機がしてているっていう状態で毎日を過ごし
ています
そしてかなり効率的に一生懸命働いているのにそういう状態
そして能力がある人でも
管理職の打診をされた時にこれ以上時間を費やさなきゃいけないとか
責任が重くなったらとてもやりきれないと言って
断ったりするっていう事例もよく聞きます
もう一つは介護の問題です
介護に携わっている人というのは今のサラリーマン男性の中でも40代50代の人が
増えてきてますからかなりたくさんいるはずなんですけれどもこれがなかなか企業内で
は露出してこないんですね
私たちの会社でも働き方改革をするに宿って
テレワークの人を募った時にですね対象者として介護の人も手を挙げてくださいって
言ったんです
全然出てこなくて
そこはやっぱりなんかその評価が下がるんじゃないかとか
何か自分のマイナスになるんじゃないかっていう意識が働いてしまうんじゃないかと
思います
そういうような問題があります
こういう情報が出てきているので今の学生さんや若い新社会人の人たちはそういうもの
を察知してしまって
まあ仕事はほどほどに行って楽しく過ごせた方がいい
とか
10歳という有能な女子学生が残業や転勤のない一般職を志望するって言うような
ケースが出てきています
の状態ってその個人個人働く人たちは
彼らが自分の能力が生かされないそして会社としても能力を生かし切れないということ
で
社会人になろうとしていう人たちもその諦め諦めの感覚が入っている状態ですよね
諦めながらまぁこれでいいやっていう形で就職をしようとしているという相当をもった
いない状態だと思っています
そしてこのように働く1人1人が能力を発揮しきれずその仕事をするなかで自己実現に
届くにはちょっと程遠い状態
そして勝つ企業の方もそこにい有能な人がいるのに能力がここにあるのにそれを生かし
きれないという不幸のスパイラルが待っている
そういう状態だと思いますこの状態が
ものすごく問題なんじゃないかと私は捉えています
個人も企業も幸せな状態ってどういう状態か
各働く1人1人の能力を引き出してそれを生かしさらにそれを高めることそしてそれを
企業がちゃんと活かして利益につなげていくことそういう状態だと思います
かなり卑近な例なんですけれども先々週私のところで実際起きた話でして私の会社 it
の会社なんですけれども
お客様への提案資料とかをパワーポイントで作るんですねそういうのをだいたい
私たちのような se が作るんですけど se なんて絵心ないんですよね
ねあの私の
もまったくもってダメなんですけれどもそういう人たちが一生懸命そのお客様にこれを
伝えたい
初級するにはどういう絵にしたらいいんだろうとどういうイラストを使えばいいん
だろう
何色にしたらいいんだろうとかそこにやたら時間かけるわけです
すごい効率悪いです
たまたまなんですけれどもその時にある部署にそういうのがすごい得意な人がいるって
言うのを聞いて
ちょっとこれ大事な仕事だからお願いだから頼むと言ってですね
このページのコンセプトはこれでこういうことを言いたいんだということをちゃんとお
伝えして作ってもらいました
そしたらもう圧倒的な生産効率て私が何時間かけても出来上がらないようなもの加工
出てきたわけですよね
その人の価値を生かしてそういう成果が上がる
で私はその人にその集合と託すことによって次のことを考えられるっていうような状態
がありました
そういうのがちゃんと回っていくことがいいんじゃないかと
私がその色を選ぶことに何時間も増えることなんか何の価値もありませんしその
デザインできる人にみんなと女
重要なプログラムを組ませることには価値がないと思います
そのように会社の中でもいろんな能力を持っている人がいるのでそれをちゃんと
引き出して認めて評価して生かしていくっていうことが重要なんじゃないかという風に
考えています
い企業で行われている
働き方開学の取り組みっていうのはこういうようなものです
テレワークをしましょう残業に規制をかけましょう
業務の無駄をとっていきましょう業務を自動化できると火事増加しましょうっていう
ような動きがあります
実際にテレワークができたり残業の規制が入ることで先ほど言った
子育てのままの問題であるとか介護の人の問題が
いくらか解決されて彼らが諦めていた働き方ができるようになったりします
その可能性が高まります
そして業務の中で無駄なことはなんだって言ってそれを排除していったり
まだなってですが単純作業を自動化することでヒト科ヒトが雑務から解放されてより人
がやるべきクリエイティブな仕事に従事する
そういうことができるようになります
しかしそれだけではダメでその次のステップに行かないとその個々の能力を生かすって
いうところに行かないんじゃないかというふうに思っています
のような仕組みやルールのところが整えられて働き方が選べる状態になりました
そして雑務から人が解放されるようになりました
じゃあ皆さん存分に力を発揮して自分の能力を発揮して仕事をしてください
いう状態になった時に住んだりくるとかっていう問題です
そこには仕組みやルールではなくてその企業にある意識や風土の問題があると思います
どういう感じ
私が想定する三つの問題ですけれども
まず1つは言いたいことが言えない
それはその
何でも言えばいいよっていう話ではなくて仕事っても目的があるわけですからその目的
に向かって到達していくために良いアイディアがあったり考えがあるのにそれを十分に
発言できないっていうことがあるということです
入りでよくある話なんですけれども自分の冗長とか
会議の中でもここへのを吹き女の人が発言したことに対して違うんだけどなあとか
もっと0愛では持ってんだけどならみたいな事を言えなくてそのまま飲み込んだり
すぐっていうパターンが結構あります
企業の方はわかりますよね
そういうこと結構あります実際にありますでえっと
そういうことがあるということと後その一つの例はですね私がその後
自社の中で働き方改革を進めようとするときに
てればこうしようっていう推進をしていったんですね昨年のことです
てるは腰を会議もビデオ会議でいいじゃんっていうふうに進めてたんですけれどもそう
いう子ディスカッションしている中である
わりと若い30代男性がですね
ビデオ会議だと相手の人が頷いてるんだから怪訝な顔してるんだかわからないから不安
だ
って言ったんですかを入れを見えないから不安だと
それを聞いて最初私もまあそうかもねと思ったんです
だけどその後よくよく考えてみたらどうして相手が胸付いているのか
怪訝な顔してるのかわかんなきゃいけないのこと
会社の会議ってロジカルに住んでいるはずなので
賛成なら賛成反対なら反対と表明すればいい話ですよね
それに対して何か議論があるなら言えばいいし相手の議論を聞いて受け入れるなら
受け入れればいいて自分の発言を却下するならすればいい
って思うんですけれどもそういう状態にはなくてやっぱり顔色を気にしてしまうって
いう現実がある
ということですそれってその目的達成に向けて生産性が高いとはいえない状態です
一つは自分で自分に好枠を作っちゃってないかという話です
それがこんなことを良いことを考えた気がするんだけど
こんなことを言ってもまあまあ無理でしょとか
あとその自分が課長じゃないから担当者たんだから業績の言葉で考えなくてもいいねぇ
とかあと自分のプロジェクトとは違う
なんか隣の部署のプロジェクトの話だからなんかちょっといい情報仕入れた
んだけど口出ししてもねとかそういうような自分で枠を作っているんじゃないかと
いう問題もあるかと思います
それは本当に無理なんでしょうか言っちゃダメなんでしょうか
それを言うことによって例えばう相手の役に立つかもしれないし自分がそれで一弾成長
できるかもしれないんです
自分で枠を作っているということはあのかなり私懸念しています
一つはこれは企業や組織の文化とか風土の問題なんですけれども
みんなの能力を見つけて引き出すっていうよりはみんなが失敗しないようにこう底上げ
していくっていう感じの教育施策などが取られているんじゃないかと思います
その底上げを底上げて今まで経験してきた企業の人たちが失敗することの痛さをわかっ
ていますからそれをしないようにやるっていうのは正しいと思います
ただその個々の能力を見つけて引き出してさらに上げていくっていう観点がちょっと
まだ薄いのかなと思ってまして
これから今後の働き方に関
してばそういうことか重要になってくるんじゃないかなというふうに考えています
そして企業はまぁまぁそういう状態なんでそこで順々に改善はしていくんですけれども
私の期待は若い皆さん学生さんたちです
フレさん達というかまぁ若い世代私の息子もですね今年19歳になるんですけれども彼
らは生まれた時からいろんな情報を耳にしたり目にしたりしていう音楽の指向性も多種
多様
周りにも結構外国人がいたりしていろんな発言や
違うものを目にしていると思ってい
ません
それで今私たちのアラフィフがですね女の人が全員ピンクレディーの ufo 踊れる
ような世代なんで施工が乞う結構
一極集中なんですよねまあそういう時代とは違うんでしょうっていう期待をしていまし
て
みんながみんな自分はこれが好きとかあれが好きとかいうふうに言えるんじゃないかな
と
そうであってほしいなーという期待をしています
ただ一つ懸念はですね今の就職活動をしている人たちの姿を見ると私たちから私から
見ると全然土産がつかないんですよね
みんな女の髪を食ってしまってですね黒いスーツで白いシャツで黒いカバー持って同じ
形に見えると
まあそれはその
がそのさっき言った一番下のハードルは
超えようと戸田のことして落とされても困るから超えていこうっていう話だと思うん
ですけれども
そのことによって何か自分の価値をこうアピールすることに
をスポイルしてみませんかともったいないことしてませんかっていうのはちょっと
問いかけになります
ああああああ
のように働くにあたってその仕事の目的へ向かって一人ひとりの能力を十分に発揮
するっていう働き方が今後望ましいし今行っている働き方改革はいろんな施策をとって
ますけれどもこういうところへ向かっていくべきなんじゃないかと向かっていって
ほしいなというふうに考えています
ああああああ
その能力をちゃんと活かして企業がそれを評価し生かして利益につなげていく
そういう社会になっていくためには
企業で働く皆さんは空気を読むよりもその目的へ効率よく達成することを真面目に
考えるべきじゃないかと
続きを読んで目的達成に向けて例えばいい権があるのに言わないことって結構その仕事
に対して
不誠実なんじゃないかとちょっと
あえて毒っぽいですけれども不誠実んじゃないかなというふうに思います
真面目にその目的に達成しようと思えば多少誰かの機嫌が悪くなろうが言うべきなん
じゃないかなというふうに思っています
そして先ほど言ったまぁちょっと空気を読まないということところに近いところもある
かもしれないんですけれども自分の枠を越えてもっと自分を成長させるそこにもう
ちょっと貪欲になっていかなきゃいけないじゃないかなと感じています
て起業の受け入れが企業の受け入れ側の文化としてはそういう違う意見もたくさん
取り入れてその9
関西とか個性とかその人に持っている特徴みたいなものをちゃんと活かしていくって
いうことを考えて
企業文化を創っていくというか企業の利益につなげていくっていうことを考えるべきで
はないかなというふうに思います
これらのことが
意外とその働き方とかコンボの
企業としてのあり方っていうところに意識の面ですけれども重要な要素になっていくん
じゃないかなというふうに思います
企業で働いている皆さん
これから就職活動をしようとしている学生の皆さん
働き方改革のその先に何を見ていると
いるんでしょうか
[拍手]